bienvenidos a reporteros de france 24 el
documental hoy los llevaremos a irak en
octubre de 2019 un movimiento de
protesta encendió las calles de bagdad
la capital de irak y de ciudades con
predominancia chiíta al sur del país
árabe centenas de miles de jóvenes
salieron a protagonizar una revolución
que sacudió al sistema político los
manifestantes estaban enojados por la
corrupción generalizada por la falta de
oportunidades laborales pero también por
la influencia del vecino irán y sus
milicias la represión fue extremadamente
violenta y dejó al menos 600 muertos y
21 mil heridos en pocos meses nuestros
reporteros se reunieron con las familias
de las víctimas que reclaman justicia y
también con algunos activistas que ahora
viven en la clandestinidad irak la
revolución asesinada es un reportaje
realizado por los enviados especiales de
france 24 amaral ya mihdawy y jonathan
walls
i
[Música]
no
los manifestantes han abandonado el
centro de kerbalá
[Música]
muchos murieron aquí durante los
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas del
orden
otros fueron fríamente asesinados
entre ellos hija balbás ni una de las
figuras más respetadas de la protesta
lo siento
[Aplausos]
con el mando
el día
[Aplausos]
el sábado
dt
[Música]
la familia de hija balbás ni se reúne en
su tumba 40 días después de su muerte
[Música]
y mataron a una voz libre a un
nacionalista él solo quería una vida
digna para su pueblo mejorar la vida de
las personas y también revelar la verdad
sobre esos partidos y esas milicias esas
milicias que matan al pueblo iraquí
desde hace años y que quieren robar sus
riquezas para dárselas a otras potencias
como irán oa otros países
y
yo los veo están en todas partes caminan
con plena libertad tal vez nos están
mirando en este momento sin que nosotros
lo sepamos son unos cobardes y unos
traidores unos traidores quisiera que la
justicia revele el nombre de los
asesinos si no puede cumplir con su
deber entonces no sirve para nada
escucharemos a menudo de estas
acusaciones directas en un país donde
las facciones armadas son más numerosas
y más poderosas que nunca
[Música]
decenas de activistas han sido
asesinados desde finales de 2019
eran los líderes de la revolución de
octubre
un movimiento masivo e inédito que
denuncia la corrupción de la clase
política y el dominio de las potencias
extranjeras sobre irak
[Música]
y
aquí fue donde lo asesinaron
mi hermano estaba llegando en el auto de
este lado
y estaba maniobrando para quedar en el
sentido de la salida
cuando le dispararon el auto rodó solo
hacia atrás hacia este muro se detuvo
exactamente aquí
[Música]
ese 9 de mayo de 2021 una cámara de
seguridad grabó el asesinato
[Música]
pero el vídeo de mala calidad no permite
identificar a los asesinos
[Música]
eran las doce y cinco una hora
cuidadosamente escogida él regresaba con
la cena del ramadán y de repente
escuchar al vecino gritar decía mataron
al hab cuando llegue al auto no lo
reconoció su rostro estaba cubierto de
sangre estaba tendido en el asiento del
copiloto lo levantaron y vi que le
habían dado en la cabeza decía que
estaba en peligro y que todo el tiempo
corría el riesgo de ser asesinado que no
sabía cuándo lo matarían nos decía que
casi en mula lo amenazaba desde hacía un
año y medio que un día lo eliminaría
[Música]
procedente de kerbalá case muslo es un
alto dirigente de la salsa vi un
poderoso grupo paramilitar
hoy en día integrado por las fuerzas
armadas iraquíes es arrestado tras la
queja de la familia al barniz furioso el
grupo us multiplica las demostraciones
de fuerza particularmente en la zona
verde de bagdad
barrio altamente asegurado sede del
gobierno el ejército no interviene
él xavi rodea la zona verde y el primer
ministro no reacciona pero en qué país
vivimos si él mismo no puedo decir nada
dónde está la ley hoy en día las
milicias controlan todo el país el
pueblo el ejército por el ejército
iraquí no puede hacer nada ante esas
noticias
aouate la semana de llevar el ministerio
el nuevo barça a las fuerzas del orden
dejaron que algunas milicias desfilarán
durante unas horas por el centro de
bagdad
en caso de malentendido o enfrentamiento
no queremos causar un baño de sangre en
las calles del país
el alcalde además de llevarle al ateo
y hacemos las liberados después de dos
semanas de detención y recibido como un
héroe por sus hombres
hay que saber que no es para trabajar
que podamos tener
a
liberar a semejante acusado de esa
manera un hombre tan poderoso
necesariamente influenciar a la
investigación es asegurar que los
testigos se retractaran y eso fue lo que
pasó
[Música]
este hombre cercano al grupo a ser xavi
niega estas acusaciones y denuncia una
satanización
a la mía
todo esto hace parte de la propaganda
difundida por ciertos medios
les meten en la cabeza estas acusaciones
contra los grupos sin aportar pruebas
eso fue lo que pasó con la madre de
isaac albéniz ella acusa a kassen
moosland pero la justicia lo disculpo
para abajo
[Música]
a pesar de los compromisos en los
niveles más altos del estado de la
investigación aún sigue en un punto
muerto en la ciudad santa chiíta de
kerbalá
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en bagdad personas cercanas a los
activistas asesinados llegan de todos
los rincones del país poco después de la
muerte de hija balbás ma
[Aplausos]
[Música]
organizamos esta congregación porque no
revelan los nombres de los que
asesinaron a los activistas los que
mataron a jabal was ni a mi padre fahy
mal type siempre mienten sobre estas
investigaciones
muy involucrada la misión de la onu
trata de hacer presión
[Música]
y al barniz era muy respetado era una
persona a la que yo escuchaba porque no
solo era una activista sino también un
realista y eso es lo que irak necesita
así que cuando me enteré de que había
sido asesinado que devastada el primer
ministro ha repetido varias veces que
para él es muy importante que la
investigación avance mientras continúe
hay esperanza pero claramente las cosas
podrían ir más rápido
entiendo la complejidad de la situación
pero solo puedo pedirle a las
autoridades que aceleren el proceso y se
aseguren de que se haga justicia
[Música]
yo estoy en una mirilla
wenders oración house una milicia me
envió un emisario que le dijo que sentía
me mataría
nunca salgas lec hasta la
ahora es oficial difícil decir sus
nombres porque si lo hago pienso que
moriré
hussein algarabía estuvo en la cerilla
una ciudad del sur que fue durante mucho
tiempo el epicentro de las protestas es
un rostro esencial del movimiento en una
región vital para la economía iraquí
[Aplausos]
quien mete en ese tema
en el pasado
hoy en día lleva una vida de hombre
perseguido su vivienda familiar fue el
blanco de un artefacto explosivo
el gobierno no hace su trabajo no revela
los nombres de los asesinos de los que
cometen actos terroristas como se les
llama eso hacer estallar las casas de
los civiles es terrorismo abuela
sugerida después de la explosión y luego
cuando presentamos una queja no recibió
tratar natural
hussein alborada y sueño hoy en día con
un destino político
cuál es la ley
tengo un deber moral después de los
sacrificios de quienes murieron durante
la revolución
debo ser portador de su voz el
sufrimiento que afecta a las ciudades
del sur y a chivas es el mismo que en
los tiempos de saddam hussein- la
justicia social infraestructura es mi
trabajo todo eso hizo que las personas
se sublevaran eso es la revolución de
octubre
es en este sur de seriedad o donde las
milicias han reclutado en masa para
combatir al grupo estado islámico el
ayatolá alí sistaní la mayor autoridad
chiíta en irak hace un llamado para
tomar las armas contra los yihadistas en
2014 la potencia de esos grupos tienen
un aumento sin precedentes con la ayuda
del gran vecino hoy en día son acusados
de querer acallar la revolución de
octubre
[Música]
y
nosotros los habitantes del sur somos
los hijos del sufrimiento y grato
venimos de las ciudades que ellos
pretenden descender
pero desafortunadamente apuntaron sus
armas y silenciadores hacia los otros
piensan que el estado iraquí que soñamos
representa su desaparición el fin de las
minis
[Música]
nos dirigimos hacia basora capital del
sur petrolero
irán está a tan sólo unos kilómetros y
la influencia de las milicias aquí es
particularmente fuerte
[Música]
los muros de la ciudad narran el destino
trágico de reagan ya q
asesinada en agosto de 2020
universitaria brillante esta feminista
se dio a conocer mucho antes de la
revolución de octubre al crear un centro
deportivo en una región muy conservadora
sus padres evocan una personalidad fuera
de lo común
[Música]
no
llevó a cabo su proyecto sola sin
nuestra ayuda
dirigía el gimnasio más grande de basora
muchas mujeres acudían a ella tenía
entre 400 y 500 seguidoras sin hablar de
quienes la seguían por las redes
sociales
ya no las mujeres de basora tenían miedo
ella las liberó les dio confianza en sí
mismas real era muy ambiciosa con
frecuencia decía que quería convertirse
en ministra de deportes eso nos hacía
sonreír le deseamos pero cómo harás eso
juanse
pero el compromiso de risk and jackie
toma rápidamente un giro más político
en esta ciudad donde a los habitantes
les hace falta todo la joven aprovechó
su popularidad como durante esta
manifestación en 2018
william james que tiene marcha del
arbainiya manos la trabajadora le hizo
pensar sólo en esta vida
en esta época lo di a raimon era muy
cercana rijan las dos mujeres se
manifiestan encabezando la multitud
su compromiso incluso atrae la atención
del consulado estadounidense de basora
que les hace una invitación
y el kremlin
era una fiesta organizada por el día de
la mujer el consulado le daba un
reconocimiento a las mujeres influyentes
de basora se publicaron fotos muestras
con el cónsul y nos trataron de
colaboradoras una ola de incitación al
odio se orquestó en las redes sociales
para mí eso fue lo que puso rija menos
agradar
[Aplausos]
cuando la protesta alcanzó una amplitud
inédita a finales de 2019
yakup decide exponerse menos
públicamente pero esa medida de
precaución no sería suficiente fue
asesinada el 20 de agosto de 2020
versión
un motociclista le disparó según lo que
me dijeron murió en el acto y recibió
dos balas en la cabeza
una en el pecho y otra en el cuello
era una gran mujer no sé qué más puedo
decir fue una pérdida para todas las
iraquíes y dinero
una importante agencia de prensa iraquí
volvió a mencionar su visita al
consulado justo antes de su muerte
[Música]
para su padre el vínculo con el
asesinato es indudable ese periódico
publicó un artículo acusando a las
personas recibidas por el consulado de
tener relaciones sospechosas con los
estadounidenses pero simplemente se
trataba de una invitación crees que
elimina hasta el jefe de la cia era sólo
una muchacha joven en su auto que les
hizo a ustedes fue porque dijo que el
agua de basora no era potable porque
pedía una vida mejor para los demás ella
no necesitaba nada simplemente sintió
que su país se estaba desplomando
el primer ministro de irak y se dirige a
la casa de los padres de ri hung ya que
después de su muerte asume un compromiso
en frente de las cámaras
sus acciones y su compromiso con esta
querida ciudad de basora los asustaron
juro por la sangre de ree ham
la sangre de todos los mártires iraquíes
que los criminales no quedarán impunes
la policía identifica rápidamente un
sospechoso
miembro de asaib ahl al-haq y una
facción pro iraní
la unidad de élite de la policía trata
de arrestarlo pero se enfrenta con una
violenta reacción y se retira
[Aplausos]
un alto mando de los servicios de
inteligencia de basora nos confirmará
estos sucesos
el portavoz del grupo incriminado nos da
su versión de los hechos
[Música]
niebla
de los medios enemigos han hecho todo lo
posible por inflar esta historia esa
persona insisto no es parte de asia
y las primeras víctimas de esas
operaciones de asesinatos son los grupos
de la resistencia y el hast
es demasiado fácil acusarlos después de
cada asesinato
se confirmó que hay una injerencia
estadounidense detrás de todo esto
y quien quiera entender la situación
debe darse cuenta de que los asesinatos
de los manifestantes no son nada nuevos
ya lo han hecho
en basora el clima de impunidad obligó
al odia reimond a huir ella también
víctima de una tentativa de asesinato
ya no hay una vida posible en basora la
muerte está en todas partes o estás con
las milicias o mueres no puedes expresar
tu opinión controlan hasta los medios
incluso los periodistas están comprados
no quiero decir nombres pero la mayoría
fueron comprados después del asesinato
del periodista ahmad antes amar basora
desapareció a nivel mediático desde
entonces
ahmad abdesamad era el corresponsal de
la cadena nacional de la invasora
periodista comprometido cubrió sin
descanso la revolución de octubre
[Música]
vamos
con el masculino
yo maestro
macua y américa tras decir
ahmad abdesamad fue asesinado el 10 de
enero de 2020 siempre bajo el mismo
modus operandi su colega safaga lee
estaba al volante murió unas horas
después a causa de sus heridas
[Música]
y estaba todavía estaba vivo cuando lo
transfirieron al hospital cuando llegué
dijeron que es el hermano de akhmad y me
dejaron acercarme a él
logré ver asafa antes de su muerte
todavía respiraba le pregunté dónde
estaba marc y en ese momento perdí el
control y empecé a insultar a los
colaboradores a irán porque yo acuso
irán de estar detrás de todo esto
la investigación sobre este asesinato es
una de las pocas en haber conducido a un
arresto
un grupo es inculpado pero la justicia
no procedió a realizar ninguna condena
[Música]
y
los asesinos fueron detenidos fueron
identificados
son parte de los ataques bola fue el
primer ministro el que lo dijo no fui yo
solo estamos esperando que se presenten
ante los jueces para el veredicto final
pero el problema es que esa etapa se
aplaza constantemente
[Música]
solicitamos en vano reunirnos con un
responsable del kata hezbollah una de
las facciones armadas más cercanas al
poder iraní creada gracias al apoyo de
los guardianes de la revolución
bien
[Música]
y
t
el blanco de los asesinatos selectivos
son los líderes de la protesta pero se
inscriben en una campaña de violencia
sistemática que se remonta a los
orígenes del movimiento la represión de
las manifestaciones provoca un baño de
sangre desde los primeros días de la
revolución de octubre
[Música]
[Aplausos]
las armas que se utilizaron contra los
manifestantes van más allá del
entendimiento las heridas eran heridas
de guerra es realmente una represión que
yo casi nunca he visto en el marco de
unas manifestaciones la responsabilidad
del gobierno iraquí está directamente
implicada porque lo gestionaron de esa
manera
luce tan helado entre el primero de
octubre y el 31 de diciembre de 2019
hubo 600 muertos eso no es poco eso
nunca pasó entre 2003 y 2021 600 muertos
21 mil heridos 29 mil encarcelados el
grado de represión era terrible
la renuncia del primer ministro iraquí
en noviembre de 2019 no pone fin a las
violencias una comisión oficial es la
encargada de documentar las violaciones
a los derechos humanos pero quedó
reducida al silencio
[Música]
nos pidieron varias veces que nos
rebelaremos los resultados de nuestras
investigaciones los organismos del
estado siempre trataron de minimizar la
cantidad de víctimas las cifras son un
lenguaje universal y revelan las
verdades de los sucesos de lo que pasa
en el terreno
hoy en día las fuerzas de seguridad
aceptan una parte de la responsabilidad
pero afirman haber limpiado sus filas
[Música]
y además en varias ciudades donde hubo
abusos policiales los responsables
quienes dispararon balas reales fueron
detenidos y condenados
algunos actuaron de manera individual
otros porque se sentían en peligro
pero algunos actores esenciales de la
represión nunca fueron molestados
durante los primeros meses de la
protesta los manifestantes se
convirtieron en blancos durante actos
ilegales de extrema violencia
existe refiere a los francotiradores que
disparaban desde los techos de los
edificios solo puedo confirmar que se
produjo al comienzo de las
manifestaciones
esos francotiradores eran parte de las
fuerzas de seguridad oficiales o de un
grupo armado que operaba por fuera del
control del estado creo que esa última
es la hipótesis correcta unas fuerzas
más poderosas que el estado no querían
escuchar esas voces y reprimieron las
manifestaciones quienes son ese
esfuerzos necesitamos una investigación
exhaustiva para saberlo las fuerzas de
seguridad del estado fueron acusadas y
hay que reconocer que fueron infiltradas
[Música]
verle desayunar y tersa thriller de
scary
haber tiene una rama armada los
centristas tiene una rama armada y
otras mil se están viendo son ellos los
que escapan al control del estado son
ayudas que tienen vehículos ni matrícula
los que utilizan silenciadores entonces
cuando se cometen crímenes claro
acusamos a ellos
[Música]
si bien nadie pone en duda la
implicación de grupos armados un actor
clave es regularmente designado como el
cerebro de la represión el general iraní
qasem soleimani comandante de las
fuerzas de élite de los guardianes de la
revolución en otoño de 2019 viaja con
frecuencia a irak durante los primeros
meses de protesta
qasem soleimani en persona estableció un
comité por supuesto no lo llamó comité
de represión era un comité de
estabilidad y seguridad algo de ese
estilo
suleman ya en persona elaboraba el
programa cotidiano de la represión de
ese movimiento de protesta no somos
buenos contestación
el gran arquitecto de la expansión iraní
en la región se apoya sobre una
abundante red de milicias
[Música]
un sábado
tenemos al menos 75 organizaciones
milicianas que dependen ideológica y
geopolíticamente de la república
islámica de irán es decir que su lealtad
está directamente con ali jamenéi y no
con el primer ministro iraquí loco mi
ministro oletta y era yo
[Música]
ante las incesantes violencias los
manifestantes acusan abiertamente a su
poderoso vecino
[Música]
algunas representaciones diplomáticas
iraníes se convierten en blancos en
varias ciudades del sur
según se manifestación se nota que esos
jóvenes esas manifestaciones son un
ataque a su influencia
es una amenaza para el poder regional
que irán desea tener
entonces es necesario callar los
silencio
la respuesta es obvia para terán o quien
afirma que washington está detrás de la
revolución de octubre una nueva manzana
de la discordia en el conflicto que
opone a los dos enemigos jurados en irak
el día supremo iraní en persona pública
un mensaje denunciando un complot con el
objetivo de sembrar la división
la atención sube un escalón más a
finales de 2019 en el punto álgido de la
protesta ataques estadounidenses dejan
decenas de muertos entre las filas del
hatha de hezbollah
grupos armados organizan una
congregación delante de la embajada de
eeuu en bagdad varios de sus líderes más
influyentes están presentes
[Aplausos]
según mis informaciones y estoy muy
informado ninguna embajada occidental
ayuda a los manifestantes
a la existencia de una rebelión chiíta
laica que exige los derechos humanos y
no el reinado de los turbantes eso fue
lo que aterrorizó a irán
durante la noche del 2 al 3 de enero de
2020 eeuu le da un golpe sin precedentes
a irán
un ataque con drone que elimina a qasem
soleimani en bagdad junto con abu made y
almohades responsable militar del grupo
a ser xavi
a la furia de sus seguidores le
responden los gritos de júbilo de los
manifestantes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este amor
de baja
no me saldrá
cada vez que la infracción
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero la euforia dura poco las facciones
armadas cierran filas tras la muerte del
soleimani
[Música]
hasta el poderoso múqtada al sádr
nacionalista reivindicado a ser
rápidamente un llamado para que termine
el movimiento de protesta sus hombres
están encargados de proteger las
congregaciones pero las disputas con los
manifestantes se multiplican
con este seguro
dijo
en febrero de 2020 los sadristas fueron
acusados de haber matado varios
manifestantes en la ciudad santa de
nayaf
y vuelve
bien
al denunciar el control de los partidos
religiosos y de sus brazos armados la
revolución de octubre puso en cuestión
los fundamentos del nuevo estado iraquí
después de 2003 el sistema confesional
le otorgó un lugar preponderante a los
chiítas perseguidos bajo sadam usen los
líderes de esta comunidad convirtieron
entonces a sus grupos paramilitares en
actores todos poderosos
lo ilustra este desfile del grupo asier
sabe oficialmente estas tropas hacen
parte de las fuerzas regulares
pero desfilan solas para marcar el
aniversario de su creación
en presencia del primer ministro y de
los responsables de las facciones más
poderosas de irak
[Música]
para mí las milicias no están fuera del
estado
las milicias no son un estado dentro del
estado las milicias son el estado tienen
al estado
así como partidos políticos debemos
reconocer nuestros errores por haber
formado a estos grupos los hicimos tan
poderosos que se volvieron capaces de
actuar por fuera del control del estado
y eso sembró el caos
una influencia que deja poco lugar para
una justicia eficaz
luego de mustafa kd me según mi
conocimiento del gobierno de mustafa al
kadim y dispone de todas las
informaciones precisas sobre el perfil
de los actores que asesinaron a los
líderes del movimiento de protesta
tu contestación
[Música]
nos enfrentamos a un enfoque sistemático
de la impunidad no se toma ninguna
acción y los crímenes continúan
en amnistía internacional con base en
nuestras investigaciones hemos concluido
que probablemente se trataría de una
situación que podría constituir un
crimen contra la humanidad
sin control y maniche
[Música]
el miedo gana terreno y los asesinatos
continúan
el hijo de fátima al badil y una
conocida activista de basora fue
asesinado a finales de julio de 2021 una
vez más tras repetidas amenazas de las
milicias sin embargo se siguen alzando
voces para transmitir las ideas de
octubre
[Música]
basora ya no es la venecia de oriente
que solía ser
hoy en día se ha convertido en la
capital de las milicias es también una
ciudad asolada por el tráfico de drogas
los comerciantes de armas todo lo que
deseo para mi bella ciudad es que pase
la página y que el gobierno retome en su
lugar el hecho de haber voz
[Música]
el huerto dejaron nada de él
y alejamiento forzado me impide estar en
la silla en el corazón de la acción pero
a pesar de esta distancia de las redes
sociales y el celular me permite estar
involucrado en las acciones de nuestros
hermanos que todavía están ahí a veces
viajó a la ciudad en secreto aunque las
milicias los años
[Música]
hillary pero solamente ahora él habría
me gustaría que la muerte de mi hija y
de las otras víctimas de la revuelta
transmitan un mensaje
ella quería darle una mejor vida a su
pueblo agonizante
riham se fue con la cabeza en alto
gracias adiós y estamos orgullosos de
ella quien puede querer semejante caos
[Música]
gracias por acompañarnos en el programa
de reporteros de la semana recuerde que
para sintonizar este y los programas
anteriores puede ingresar a nuestra
página web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]